hello ladies and rejects I just came
back from the Hollywood Forever Cemetery
the iPass talking dead walking dead they
played on a giant screen about 2,000
fans were estimated to be there there's
an awesome event but boy am i I got a
little bit of a [ __ ] headache a lot
of head bashing in the season premiere
holy [ __ ] before I went to the Hollywood
Forever Cemetery I spent a Friday and
Saturday I rewatched the last six
episodes of season six to just get
really familiar with it and get really
pulled back into it boy whoa that uh
that really [ __ ] got me man
like it's weird because a lot of people
have died over the years on The Walking
Dead but there's never been such a
build-up and such a mystery as to who
died I mean a lot of people guessed they
la people guessed it correctly actually
but I didn't guess it correctly though
that was a really well-done episode
first off just the episode itself as
well there's gonna be spoilers in this
video I'm gonna try to keep it short the
first like half hour of that whole
episode are like 40 minutes was just so
intense it was it was like I was
uncomfortable I I don't think I've ever
seen an episode of The Walking Dead that
had me that much on the edge of my seat
that much in such a dark world like I
was so pulled into it yet I was so
disturbed and I felt those feelings that
Rick must have been feeling that sense
of despair that sense of loss like I
felt really I felt like it was really
getting to me I was shocked
you know when they when they finally
revealed like the first person that
negan kill when he when he smashes
Abraham in the head Abraham sits up he's
got blood trickling down suck my nuts
like that was a cool way for Abraham to
go out it was violent as [ __ ] it was
brutal they did not hold back but when
it was done it was like okay okay it's
all said and done it's finally done it's
still hurtful it's still shocking
but then when Darryl goes to punch negan
like I love the way this whole episode
was written directed edited acted it was
like the one of the best episodes I've
ever seen of The Walking Dead I really
feel like they had their like a Plus
game on and during this episode when
Abraham got killed it was still shocking
because it wasn't just like a beat to
the head and then he was just going
dizzy like when he got hit
it looked [ __ ] painful and then when
Abraham says suck my nuts are like holy
[ __ ] he's still conscious what the hell
it's not like he's just dizzy out of
control like he he still has some of his
like senses together he's aware of
what's happening to him and it's cool
that Abraham went out in the style that
like when they when it when they had the
line of oh he's taking it like a champ
like it was a great way to give that
in-service to Abraham cuz in the last
season we see it through his first
person point of view which was Greg cuz
I'm like yeah then that would make sense
for Abraham to be that one till I just
get back up and take it but dude when
Daryl punched me and I was like what the
[ __ ] I was in the crowd people started
applauding cuz people were alone yes my
back but I was like no don't don't do it
and why'd he do it
I thought Daryl was for sure gonna die
and then he yeah that was a great moment
when when they killed Glenn because a it
does on the comic it looks like the
comic cuz when he first gets smashed in
his heads like dented in his eyeball is
like he gives his left eyeball it's like
popping out and it was such a disturbing
sight
cuz it's Glenn you're like holy [ __ ]
that's glad Indies is the boy man and
talking dead you know Chris Hardwick
kept saying it he's the heart of the
show so so was like having your heart
broken and Abraham is such a character
of strength so you're getting rid of
such a the character of strength and
then they killed off the guy with the
heart and when the Glenn said I think
what Glenn said was I'll find you Maggie
it was so heartbroken
Harper Elmer I'm losing my words man
it's not an easy episode to sit through
when when Glenn said I'll I'll find you
Maggie
it's that moment you could just feel
what our heroes are Kara the
protagonists we're feeling like there's
nothing they can do they are they are
losing now they're becoming weak and
then when he gets his [ __ ] brains
bashed in and then they do that shot
it's it looks like it's right out of the
comic book budding color and it's life
where you see his brains on the ground
you see his eyeball on the ground the
need has to go make that comment to you
before he like completely bashes Glenn
to death about you know like man I just
popped your eyeball out or something I I
was in shock because it was clever
writing it was clever editing when you
you really do believe that like okay
Abraham is dead all right we finally
finally found out her answer and then
what Daryl punched him you think
Darryl's gonna die but no negan just
knows how to get under people's skin
even more so to me it was like he was
punishing Daryl by killing Glenn instead
I really feel like that's gonna be a
major effect on Daryl because as an
audience member like everyone in the
crowd loves Daryl and then he got the
most like I love you Daryl love you
Norman throughout the whole when Norman
Reedus was on stage for talking dead but
I couldn't help but be a little bit
upset it they're like dude [ __ ] guy
Glen killed but it didn't just end with
like that and then they like leave I
really noticed the last few episodes of
season six we're really about
establishing how Rick was confident and
he believed in the strength of the team
and that they can't they nothing can
stop them the world is there Sivan says
at one point Sam is shown but this
episode was really about tearing Rick
down that was such an intense scene when
I mean you know Rick's probably gonna
survive but man was that [ __ ] intense
when cuz negan's this is the master
villain of the show he's one of the best
villains I've ever seen portrayed on
television or in movies because this
might help [ __ ] up negan
is there are times where you're like
Gammy's such a good actor though he's
still kind of charming even though I
hate his guts that whole moment was
fantastic when when Rick you know when
Rick had to go retrieve the axe and then
he has to deal with all these walkers in
the fog and at one point he's hanging
off the guy who was hung in the last
episode and then his neck stretches up
and Rick's falling into the crowd of
walkers men that was I was so on the
edge of my seat and the whole time you
keep thinking is is Rick gonna get his
wrist is on his hand chopped up is we're
gonna get his hand chopped off people
have said that it happens so maybe it
does and he can and I feel like the the
director was aware that like people
would be anticipating that so there are
certain shots like especially on their
way back when like Rick's sitting at the
table and and negan's just you know
talking to him where you think like is
this gonna be it as his knee because the
crazy thing about negan is you just he
likes to throw you by surprise he likes
to take you off guard so even though he
kind of talks as if he's not like a man
who's gonna surprise you he no he didn't
he wants to shock you and he wants to
surprise you so you keep thinking like
at any moment negan might just kill
someone when negan's around it this
feels [ __ ] dangerous it's scary that
that great scene where negan is forcing
Rick to chop off a part of Karl's arm
and man dude like I really believed it
was gonna happen by the way how intense
that show was how [ __ ] up everything
was going it wasn't like you know in
certain screenwriting books they talked
about how you know each team must go
from a negative to a positive or a
positive to a negative and then for the
first half hour it's just like all
negative like nothing good is happening
for these guys to watch Rick cuz Rick is
that that one you can fight and Rick's
the one that always has his head on and
is always ready to be a leader and
always ready to fight back but before
he's about to chop off Karl's arm it is
kind of like it does kind of remind me
of that story in the Bible
of when God is testing Abraham - and
there's a lot of like metaphors and
analogies and themes of Christianity
that are thrown into this show and it
does remind me of that story of when God
told Abraham to kill his own son and
then right when Abraham was about to
kill his son God's like not just testing
you man so that that's kind of what it
seemed like that this was like the devil
recreating this thing that God once did
it's like negan kind of does view
himself like he is God so I thought it
was a I don't know if that's what
happens in the comics I didn't read that
part of the graphic novel but the way it
was executed in the show was really well
done because I really believed it was
gonna happen
I can't I've seen every episode but I
don't know if I'm remembering it wrong I
can't recall a time where you see Rick
really just feel like he's he's lost and
he surrenders to the evil power and he
is he's he's willing to accept defeat
and he just he's just trying to stay
alive he's trying to keep his friends
alive he's trying to keep the rest of
the group alive watch what happens in
mad respect to Carl for Carl being like
just do it dad like how Carl just
everyone in that moment just felt so
defeated and by the time they all left
thank God direct didn't cut off his arm
but by the time they all left I've seen
that crowd like whoa I I feel a little
empty right now I feel like I'm in shock
that was such a hard thing to sit
through to watch all of that happen like
they really they built this up and they
[ __ ] delivered man they gave us one
of the most if not the most intense
Walking Dead episode I've ever seen
they made negan a million time he was
already had a he had a cool intro and
the season finale of season six but he's
in this episode a lot and mandus who is
it was like the first time you know ever
where I've watched him so long he didn't
like man that's that's a hard one to
shake off
I'm a little bit like I am pretty
disturbed like I just can't these
flashes of Glenn where he's like just
looking at Maggie the heads bent in and
then his eyes popping out so
heartbreaking now he has to go through
that just like a real people after a
while I mean there's gonna be so much
resolve that's gonna have to come from
this like this this really is steering
the show in a very different direction
this isn't just some cool season opener
like this is this is gonna cause a
strong ripple effect man I really want
to see me get killed I really want to
see that [ __ ] you mean Jeffrey Dean
Morgan is a badass actor but god damn do
I want to see him die and with Maggie's
like you guys got a fight man I really
felt that like like it's cool that
Maggie still huh Maggie's being that
stubborn woman who's just so he's has to
fight but damn they were she'd well
justified in that moment I like that
scene with Sasha and Rosita when they're
talking about how she's gonna take care
of Abraham's body because it's like they
were making amends with each other
without having to say it and I thought
it was very well captured and very well
acted it's a scary situation cuz you
know like it's the first time where this
isn't like an episode of yeah Rick and
the group this is an episode of like
making the audience feel like we've lost
we we are in a state of depression right
now I'm really excited to see where this
show goes from here just like I feel
like I'm mourning it's a weird feeling I
didn't think I would feel this way I
thought it was just gonna be like we
find out who but it sucks and it hurts
but we'll move on and move on to some
cool Walking Dead [ __ ] but the show
really knew how to psychologically break
down these characters and deteriorate
the well being this you know the mental
health of these characters which in turn
deteriorates us it was there's not an
easy experience to sift through and and
damn what an experience so it's a
[ __ ] good show as far as my
experience of watching talking dead I
gotta say is that the ha go forever
seven
Terry it was cool seeing all them on
stage Chris Hardwick
when the cameras are not rolling and
like he is still a really funny guy and
it was legit starting to pour rain at
one point I thought it was just cool to
be like in the part in the Hollywood
Forever Cemetery and and watching this
and then seeing that they're all getting
covered in rain oh they're all like
dressed up nice though like I got my you
know this sure from 1up box but it was
cool to just be like covered in the same
rain but sitting here with the same
experience as the actors and hearing
their their method on it and having to
say goodbye to
Stephen you and Michael was really yeah
that's an experience anyway uh yeah my
hairs all looking frizzy and wet know if
you're what you think know what happened
about the deaths how do you feel about
it uh I'm shaking this one off man if
you're new to the channel subscribe and
follow me at the greg alba on instagram
have a good night